the other day somebody calls biting on
christmas day your father says hey
president yay thank you so much for
everything and hey let's go brandon yeah
yeah let's go brandon what do you mean
yeah let's go brandon
there's there's gotta be something
missing there to not know what's let's
go brandon did you think that was
disrespectful though do do i think uh uh
lebron calling uh president trump and
effin chump disrespectful yeah that's an
influencer i think that's disrespectful
i think a guy that wasn't his fa this
was on the phone to the president let me
tell you if if a first of all you know i
don't like that kind of stuff i've never
liked that kind of it's not my style at
all to do any of that kind of stuff
i don't like you talking to a president
that way but at the same time uh if a
person is coming out and saying
something like that you ought to be
aware to pause it at that point and say
what are you talking about i'm sorry
what
that's really your best message on
christmas day yeah you're getting a
calling and you're using that
opportunity to do this that says more
about your character than it says about
yeah but but i understand why can we
show that clip or no i uh uh is it is it
on fox or cnn
see if you can pull it up on twitter and
just we'll commentate on it go ahead
david pat wouldn't you say that that if
biden would have reacted to it it's
almost like
confirming that it's almost like giving
that person more power yeah i get that
but i totally i i don't even know if he
fully knows what's let's go brandon
yeah i don't i don't know i gotta
imagine well his wife gave a an eye roll
like a side eye she knew exactly what
was going on yeah but it's not the she's
not the president no he knows what's
like there's no way that he cannot be
aware of what they're doing the
president to to just kind of say yeah
let's go brandon that's not a good game
while he's pulling this up let me tell
you something
i don't care if if i had the opportunity
to do a phone call with donald trump and
i don't think it's a secret that i'm not
a big fan of his and he's saying hey
just want to wish you and your happy
family happy hanukkah merry christmas
happy holidays wishing you the best new
year you know what i say thank you very
much mr president i wish the same to
your family and i hang up the phone and
i said i just spoke to the freaking
president united states
this isn't politics at that point to you
though you're a class act i'm just
saying like you have the opportunity to
speak to the president and you're going
to be this guy's name is schmeck i would
like him like a freaking i would like
for you to hold lebron just as
accountable when we had this
conversation four months ago and you
said i don't think that's a big deal
well there's a difference between saying
it into the just atmosphere or saying it
to the president's face no if lebron
would have been on the phone call with
trump and said trump i think you're a
piece of guy i would have said that as
guys had a chance to go to the white
house and they said we refuse to go to
the white house that's an insult i agree
so i agree with some meaning but to
their faces is so disrespectful how many
shitty comments do you get on internet
that's published you get a lot of i hate
on the internet lebron is not ever
someone wouldn't say that to your face
not everybody lebron
so all i'm saying is say that but hold
the fire on the same side of your end
don't just say it on the opposite side i
i'm not going to get on and say hey mr
joe biden president joe let's go bro
what are you doing
you get an opportunity to do this that
just says a lot about you and the guy's
probably a troll trying to make an
opportunity out of it it is what it is
all i'm saying to you is
the same people that sat there and said
man i'm just done with this sob as a
president because everything's a
freaking i need somebody a little bit
more peaceful yeah okay no problem you
keep doing that and the guy behind
closed doors making a phone call saying
take all my negative reviews down
because i am such and such from china
and they're going to constantly impose
look
let's just say you were nemesis let's
just say we're enemies you and i
but we'll go to lunch we'll have dinner
together we'll have a conversation
together and you're reasonable and
unreasonable guess what we'll make it
work make sense we'll make it work
but let's say you have not an ounce of
reason in you you don't have an ounce of
willingness to work with me yeah do you
think
i should be hiring somebody that's a
softy to go in a room with you to
negotiate yeah i don't know if i'm going
to be comfortable with that
we need somebody that's going to be able
to handle somebody like you if that's
who you're as a nemesis
what is china's dna today are they
willing to collaborate are they willing
to be reasonable is there any ounce of
reason being seen by china i don't think
so you need somebody that can handle a
situation like that and by the way i'm
not shocked about what xi jinping is
doing obviously he's silencing voices
you know i was at that gary kasparov
invited me to the freedom forum i told
this story i'll tell it again
you know it's it's dissidents from all
over the world the one iranian uh
journalist the girl with the great hair
she uh she knows who you are you know
who she is great she spoke an iraqi guy
a uyghur she's in china
i spoke to um
the uh there's one lady
she had her own
area called the firewall cafe and she
basically the whole purpose was you pull
up an internet you google
uh an example that she did was you
google
like tyler do this let's do this
experiment google
xi jinping
winnie the pooh have you seen this yeah
okay
xi jinping winnie the pooh
so if you do that in america
this is what pops up right images of xi
jinping looking like winnie the pooh
okay
he kind of has this
you know bearish demeanor okay it's
funny obviously he's not a freaking
yellow cartoon whatever
if you do that in china you know what
pops up
just images of xi jinping zero
winnie the pooh and then if did i say
all right let's try something else pull
up donald trump
if you pull up donald trump in america
here pull just images of donald trump
right
you're gonna see some good stuff some
bad stuff some family stuff some some
honorable stuff but for the most part do
you think those are bad images of donald
trump no no
every image that you put up in china is
his hair flipped to a side he's yelling
he's doing his thing
it's the censorship and it's exactly
what we talked about when the amazon
reviews it's five stars or it's nothing
how long can that last how long can
people just say i got no say i got no
voice what do you mean i mean if you
have to realize you know how you ask
somebody i like to ask people and i say
so where are you from i'm from montana
so how was it growing up here you know
what's a common answer people say
i don't know any otherwise all i know is
montana all i know what it is to grow up
in china all i know what it is to grow
up in iran all i know is what it is to
grow up in leningrad they don't know the
difference yeah so that can go on for a
long long time
i mean like let's use north korea as an
example i mean that's an extreme example
i'm not saying that north korea is china
but i mean our friend um
what's our girl's name
um you know me parker naomi park my girl
young she knew exactly why they're
trying to sneak out of north korea they
know what's going on how she got out
it was insane how she got yeah that's
not every everyone's way of getting out
so what is their aware of their horrible
lifestyle
to the point of of how long can people
go with this these were experiments run
in the 50s and the 60s long story short
they ran one experiment to see who would
shock somebody if an authority figure
told them to 65 percent of people would
kill another person if they were told to
okay and then this in this one on the
right is another experiment in the 50s
to see
how much social pressure from a majority
could affect people and the conclusion
was people were literally willing to
ignore reality to conform to the group
so it's it's peer pressure is a serious
how long can people accept this and say
we have no voice for as long as the
authorities tell them to i mean it's
it's it's it's not as far-fetched as one
might imagine
but but adam to your point about trump
destroying democracy to go after china
and we should have desantis and you have
to say destroying democracy i just you
know civility civility well you have to
think that even no matter who it is if
somebody goes after china they're going
to destroy civility because who owns
forbes now it's china right it's a
chinese company
harvard has taken a billion dollars in
donations from china and that's just
what's reported there's been over saying
exactly there's been over like 10
billion dollars given to american
universities okay
what is it called confucius schools yeah
exactly half half of uh the active
ingredients in american pharmaceuticals
come from china i mean it's they have so
much power eric swalwell was sleeping
with a chinese spy dianne feinstein's
driver for 20 years was a chinese spy i
mean if we go after china they're going
to wreck the country they have they have
their tentacles in everywhere and
they're going to pull their manipulation
and control it's going to be ugly i
think if you do or you don't they're
going to do it anyways
i think if you do or you don't they're
going to do it anyways i just think you
need a strong figure
that can go up against somebody like
that that's not scared i don't think you
need a softy to do that i think you need
somebody real so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]